[Music]
the smell of that stuff you know
it's it's alive it's not dead
i just enjoy watching mother nature
working
i mean it's it's it's intriguing i mean
if you've never been around
doing composting and then you see it
change on a daily basis as you turn it
it's impressive most people say well
that can't be that to this
it is
we've been farming roughly around 1500
acres
of uh last year was probably the most
diverse that we've
ever been and having we had rye we had
peas
we had sunflowers edible beans soy beans
alfalfa and wheat so
we from a few years ago we were just
basically doing
uh soybeans and wheat and so we have
gone to to more of a diverse farming
operation
which i think is is is helpful in
management or
or to try to get your biology going so
this is our feedlot facility which we
call hollywood feeders
here in toronto south dakota and
we're a permitted facility for 34.99
head of beef cattle
so in a standard monoslope type barn the
livestock are bedded with straw and
and then that combines with their manure
and you have
a bed pack situation olsen custom farms
we farm about 12 000 acres in
in minnesota and south dakota so dual
county
lincoln county uh minnesota
and a little bit over in hamlin county
south dakota as well
right now we farm we're right around
2200 acres
soybeans corn sugar beets and and we do
have wheat every so
we don't have any wheat this year we'll
chop some of the corn for silage but we
tend to feed a lot of the
beet pulp from the from the factory but
it's nice
again to fit in with spreading the
manure if we're chopping silage we know
we can spread some manure and compost so
that works out really well
so with the feed lot we're um we're
allowed 999 through the state
we normally run about oh there's
probably 500
that we feed in there almost all
finishing so the feed lot processes is
i'll go in about every well right around
this time
every year with the excavator and pile
our piles
pile our piles where that we put our
bedding i'll pile as high as it'll go
and then we have we have our sloped
feed lot that goes into lagoon so all
that leachate runs in the lagoon
the manure starts to dry out and then
after a while normally it's
normally it's mid-august we'll start to
haul that
that manure out we try to do it in about
two two and a half days
that's our goal anyway so we tend to
we'll hire a contractor to come in with
one of those big trucks to haul and then
i just load them with the excavator
which works really well
normally we have about um per year
we have about probably 4 000 tons of
manure
but like this year it's a double year we
really had a wet year last year so we're
trying to figure out
what we're going to do there we try to
plant our acres based on
the crop that we're going to go into i
like to go into corn but we have in the
past
done it where we'll spread on ground
that's going into sugar beets because
normally that's weak
sometimes wheat ground so we can get it
we know we're going to get it spread we
can spread lime we can spread manure
so we've done that the last couple years
like i said before not all of it gets
turned to compost of the feedlot manure
that we take out but the stuff that we
do i'll either put
close to the farm and run my windrows
there or in the past i have gone
on the edge of a field dumped the manure
and then just turned it
you know four or five times and then
it's right there we're able to spread it
on the ground so
as far as spreading we've done a little
bit of both we've had custom guys come
in and spread
our compost and our manure but the last
few years we've bought
our own vertical spreader and so we've
been able to
spread with that and then have another
neighbor that brings his over so
but we've got a lot of material now so i
think we'll probably end up doing
something
just to get rid of it all we should be
able to spread
you know probably 500 of those acres i
would imagine this year is kind of my
goal that's how much we have a lot of
material
normally i'd only like to put on about
five ton but with the material we have
it might be closer to 10 maybe 15.
i'll i'll end up doing trials with that
too just to see the difference but
with the compost i'd like to spread a
little being that i have enough of the
product
i would really like to see what more you
know a higher amount does
to kind of maybe offset some of that
fertilizer side of it
that's one thing i really want to learn
though too is you know can i move
forward using a lot less fertilizer
because it's hard
it's hard to move away as i said before
from the npk mindset
but i know especially the p and the k i
know i can replace that with the compost
through
through time i live here on five acres
in
eastern wright county with my family who
is now just two of us because all the
other all the kids are gone now
but we still have four horses we've got
the two you can see in the background
two big boys and we got two little boys
out and back
clean stalls every evening before
everybody comes in from
being out here on the pasture or out in
the dry lot manure goes into a
wheelbarrow wheelbarrow comes out here
and we
just dump it here in front of the pile
and maybe once a week or so
kind of depends on how much manure we've
had i'll take the tractor and we'll load
it back up under the pile and stir the
pile at the same time
the reason i i started first of all is
i'm concerned about
first of all organic matter and second
more so infiltration
i think we have a real problem with
infiltration and
how do you remedy that and i still don't
have an answer for that
the other thing is that we've been
losing organic matter
in our soil and and we put in
most people feel we put all this residue
into the ground
it's got to go into organic matter but
most of it goes up into the air
i went to uh acres conference and there
was a guy there that
he showed the extract
and he showed it up on the screen and
you see all those critters moving around
and it says you know those are live in
our soil
and i think we need to get them get them
back in there again
the fertility is here this is one of our
business
entities of the farm but it was
very underutilized and
it's just was begging for the
opportunity because it's the best
fertility
we could have for the farm but how are
we going to get it
out on to the acres when i joined the
farm
as the agronomist i quickly identified
in
fall of 2016 that we needed
we could do a better job with this
fertility
and make it kind of the hub of our
fertility program
but the only way we were going to be
able to do that was to get it in a
transportable
package so to speak and that's where you
fall back on the idea of composting
diversification is is important
utilizing the acres that you have soil
health
all those buzzwords compost is at the
peak of that
yeah it's been 15 years since i've
started to do this and
every year is a new experience but i
really enjoy doing it and i enjoy
talking about it and i i just think um
it's i like to use the term it's the
right thing to do and it's also i think
it's it's the way things are going i
think it's um
is we're we're taking that that
management that
stewardship to the next level and we're
taking a waste product that people don't
want to look at they think it smells
they think
it looks bad and we're turning into
something that you could
give your kids and when they could eat
it and it wouldn't harm them that's an
amazing thing to me so
for me personally i think the
combination is is really
a really good way to go and i think from
a a sector side from an agriculture
sector
sector side we're gonna have to start
moving away from the synthetic
fertilizers from
relying on that and and if we're about
building our soil health it's putting
that organic matter back on the soil
every spring i spread it out on the
pasture
give the grass some nutrition and we use
it for garden mulch
and it reduces the the volume of the
manure
probably by a third it's a very
inexpensive thing to do you do have to
have equipment to keep your
the compost pile turned over i would
hate to have to do this with a shovel
that's for sure
it would be a better operation here if i
had started this on a concrete slab
because one of the problems is over the
over
well we've been here for 25 years and uh
the the ground around the manure pile is
starting to go down just because it gets
caught up in the in the bucket of the
tractor once in a while when we
turn the pile over the manure pile
itself is a composted
stays at a fairly high temperature but
it'll only do that if you keep it
turned over and keep it aerated and give
the bacteria some
some oxygen to live on good farming you
need a mix
of of the fungal and bacteria
and that's why i've done some more of
the of the static that i will introduce
the static
in with the with the regular compost
because most of our compost i can show
you those numbers but
most of the of the uh of the compost
that we build
in the row like this it's two gets too
hot
and the fungal material doesn't survive
and i'm hoping that we can once that
these piles are probably getting cool
enough now
that that we can do the the fungal
material add that to the compost
this is some finished compost
and uh here so
this is this is what this came from and
most people have a hard time
visualizing well this is soil i mean but
it's compost that
that's gone through the process of of
with
all the microbes and everything else and
and and digesting it
and this is the final result of that and
which is very
impressive stuff i use straw i
i've used pea straw i've used
soy bean straw i've used corn straw and
we also try to get wood chips if we
possibly can
this is the first time we've been using
a larger amount of hay because
we had some of our alfalfa that was left
over from last year we're using that and
we have
in the mix that we're doing right now
it'll be 30 bales of straw
on a roll with 15 bales of alfalfa
this is last year's alfalfa
so this is a really good nitrogen source
to add then with your because what kind
of straw is this then it's rye straw
okay
from the seat of the pants
it's it's basically what you've got
available yes
we normally green chop our road ditches
as as another
forage area so that would be another
nitrogen that's right the second type
too you put water on your
probably a few times before you put the
manure on top of it
it'll get a nice even
and so do you think you'd be able to
compost here without water
no i think water is important because
this stuff is so dry
when you start with so we will probably
dump like three semi loads of manure
into this here which would be 150 000
pounds and is that manure coming out is
that a bedded pack
that bed pack that back yeah and that'll
have some hay and straw
also in there too but it should make a
pretty hot mixture i would think
i usually don't have any problem with
temperature
you said that pile over there was even
up to 120 already well
when that got turned with that moisture
in there now that'll probably by tonight
or tomorrow morning it'll be up to 140
150 degrees and that's where your
biology starts working
on there and and uh breaking down
everything
uh in in there so that'll be a good
material for the soil
when your compost gets down to ambient
temperature you can use it
or another method is i think if you put
it into a zip lock bag
and if it doesn't smell ammonia you
you're okay to spread it
you notice that this is is this ideal
place
it's it's you've got a slope on it so
anybody that
you you you can't have it in a in a slew
hole i mean
you've got to be able to access your or
do your turning
even though you've had rain so
that's this here has got a nice gentle
slope and it hit heads off over to the
side
we've got the analysis of both the
regular windrow composting and also the
static compost
from the same material coming back
so if we have twelve thousand acres we
hope to apply
compost to four thousand every year
so every field will see compost
hopefully
once in every three years some people
work under their state
regulations others work under an epa
permit
but with this facility
it's easier to work under the state
regulations versus
an epa permit this particular county
you had to get a special use permit and
of course
the the neighbors concern was oh you're
gonna have more flies
more smell because now you've brought it
out
out on one particular site and not land
applied it
but with the inoculants and the
composting process
within one or two turns it's not manure
anymore it's compost and
it's basically odor free and then we'll
have
two pads where all the wind rose are
contained so we can hold
36 windrows that are 14 feet
by 160 feet long and
they're 160 feet because that's the
length of our
felt covers that we'll have over the
windrows
the felt covers are from for moisture
management because
in the composting process the microbes
want to stay at a consistent temperature
and moisture
and so excess moisture messes up that
process and
and the windrows getting too dry would
also shut that process down so
if we have them all covered we control
the moisture with
the compost turner and the car the water
cart that follows
uh we control and rain snow whatever
doesn't uh interfere with that or like
this summer we have a lot of hot windy
days
you would have to be adding water to
your windrows like
constantly the longer you have a run
the harder it is to get water away from
the windrows even on a design pad
so we shorten them up to 160s so
there'll be a
diversion channel kind of right in this
area
where the first runs water collects and
gets diverted to the containment pond so
within this site all the water
from a rain event excess water goes to
the containment
pond down there we didn't have a lot of
slope
to work with here so we have to kind of
create
this this the necessary slope
because most compost sites
you have to be able to work in you know
all the time and so it can't be a place
where water accumulates
it has to drain away because excess
moisture
uh doesn't lend itself well to
composting and that's why
we discover too that most large-scale
composting sites tend to be in more arid
areas
but over here where you have more
moisture you have to create
that condition where you can work with
your compost
on an almost daily basis because the
wind rose
will demand that this will be our
loadout spot that we're standing on here
to bring in trucks and we'll haul it to
the field
we're thinking with a live bottom truck
and then we'll meet the composter litter
spreader
out in the field and that'll have a
conveyor
so we can just back up with a live
bottom so we don't need another
payloader
we don't want a double handle in the
field that we're spreading we want that
to be efficient
the equipment to compost really
in the scope of what farm equipment
costs
isn't the obstacle because there's a
scale of composting equipment for every
size
operator it comes down to
the site and what how extensive a site
do you need
we probably wouldn't be able to permit
this facility had we not taken on
this type of manure management system
they would have had to redesign
something within
the barns or how the manures handled
because
under the new south dakota permitting
you can't
we can't store minerv for very long
outside the barn if at all depending on
what your situation is out here with the
feed lot when my father-in-law built the
feedlot
it was kind of nice because he had to to
come under
the guidelines of the feedlot runoff and
so in dealing with the manure we had a
best management practice plan
and then with the composting it fit
really well into that and and we're able
to utilize
a lot more of that product on on a wider
acre
basis as you can see out here the beets
have been the biggest challenge
most of the time you're dealing with
either a carbon source or a nitrogen
source and what i've found is
it almost goes from a carbon to a
nitrogen back and forth depending on
on the how the beets feel i mean they
start off really spongy but then as they
dry out
they get really hard basically like a
carbon source and so
finding that happy medium of of what to
do with the beets has been
has been a i won't say tough because it
it really isn't tough it's just
it's it's interesting and it's uh
i like the interesting side of compost
too so
what i found with this and and again
that's one of the main reasons i bought
my turner is
you know if a guy could start off with a
smaller particle size you would be way
better off with my machine
after two times it really breaks that
stuff down the ingredient part is the
main thing i
i have found with our manure we use we
use straw throughout the year
so we tend to have a pretty good mixture
based on just the straw
that we put in with the manure in the
feed lot i don't have to add a lot
with the beets like i say the the
moisture level can
vary so much that it's more of kind of a
feel and a look for me
so i don't really have a recipe at this
point again
um you know there's a few things i try
to do to
to start that process a little quicker
but you know over time it
you know it starts to heat up even
without turning it and then
getting that particle size down is is
kind of the main thing so
talking about mistakes and i made a lot
of mistakes is
is the carbon side of it i've i've
really come to find out
and my dad has too that you know the
manure is good but but you can have too
much of it
you know what i mean and if you're going
for a good product you don't need a
whole lot of manure i consider the
manure to be kind of a
magic elixir but you can you can get in
trouble with
with it heating up too much as far as
when you apply it especially repeat
customers
because they think a little is good a
lot must be better so i've really tried
to go away from
just doing straight manure piles out of
the feedlot we still do it
but if i'm going for a good product i'll
basically start with my carbon source
and then add the manure
here it's almost trying to keep the
moisture out of it
i deal more with with puddling which
creates a challenge even with
with the equipment you know sometimes a
two-wheel drive tractor is not enough to
even pull sometimes which is
kind of frustrating but the heavier
ground out here poses a challenge but
i've been able to get around that now
that's where hankinson comes into play
i've got some
some compost ground down by hankinson
north dakota where it's basically blow
sand
and it can be raining and i can be
turning so i love making
compost down there and it makes a really
good product too
well here it was just uh the the
closeness to the feedlot
um i didn't want to have to haul it very
far and we had a spot
uh that was close enough that that had a
you know a good enough
drainage site um that that worked and i
and i try to move my piles around so i'm
not putting it on the same spot but i
also don't want to take up a lot of
ground but
i've also done where we'll we'll pile
manure on the end of a field i'll turn
it and then we spread it right away
which
really works nice and that's a year
process the trucking cost is always
something that
i really take into account because it
can get expensive but it's no different
than
you know if you're having to haul manure
i try to take into account that and and
with the compost you're hauling a lot
less material too
the marketing side of it of course i
want to get to the point where i can
market almost all of it
i'd like i'd love to get to the point
where i have a really good product
i can find growers especially organic
guys that that
they would really appreciate a good
product that they could use
um and maybe even some of the
conventional guys to see that
you know the big thing is soil health
right now i don't know of a better way
to build your soil than put compost
other than maybe cover crops
my dad had this this exact machine he
bought his brand new
about 15 years ago i was able to find
this one used and i knew i wanted to
find the same machine if i could do that
just because
i knew it it's simple and to be honest
it makes a really good product
it's not aggressive but once the
material starts to break down it really
does a good job of incorporating
the material and also incorporating the
oxygen and
the biggest thing that i found and in
most cases you would think that you
would want the machine to turn really
fast when i start off i do
run it fast but as time goes on those
those mic
you know the microorganisms do more of
the work than the machine does
and basically what i do with this
machine is is i'm basically just
fluffing that material
and and just trying to
you know if it's reaching that
temperature that i want to turn it out
that's kind of my basis for when i turn
but
i'm not looking at being aggressive once
once it starts to break down and
those piles get get small by the by the
end of the process so
one of the downfalls of this machine is
is it doesn't quite fit a dump truck
when you're dumping
your material so you're constantly in
your loader sizing up your windrows and
that's the only downfall
that i have with this machine so now
this machine right here
was i think this cost me about fifteen
thousand dollars which i felt was a
pretty good price
um so and they're they're not easy to
find
but um but if a guy can find one and
they're they're beginning there's
beginning to be more and
with the internet you can find you can
find them more and more this machine new
with the water is is probably 50
000 i think so yeah this machine has
been a big boon to
our operation um as you can see i've got
all the flails off but i did put a
couple
a couple on here just to show you can
see how
how big these knives are compared to the
other
the other machine now the reason i
bought this
machine was is i was getting a lot more
material
and i wanted to get through it quicker
than i was getting through with that
other machine and i wanted to do
i wanted to to start with a smaller
particle size was the biggest thing
it just really um
this thing is really aggressive
it doesn't make as good a finished
product and i would recommend that's why
it's nice
i really don't want to have two machines
but it's worked out really well
that i can i can start off my piles and
and get going on them fast and handle a
lot of material i can do almost 2 500
tons
an hour with this thing
and then when the piles start to get
smaller i come through and and use that
other machine
of course it's it's more expensive
and they're harder to find and i didn't
like the self-contained engine but
it was kind of just what worked at the
time
so every one of those then will have a
knife it's got 80 knives on it yup
it makes you know going through manure
pot heavy manure
can cause a lot of issues with that
other machine if you if you
um if you have a too big of a pile this
thing
i it will go through anything it's it's
unbelievable
what's nice about the vertical beater is
i
i've used compost spreaders in the past
and i love them but we still spread
manure and you can't spread
and i'm not i'm not an all or nothing
guy i mean sometimes
you just run into problems where you
don't have the time and manure is still
a great product in my mind
so we're able to uh to kind of kill two
birds with one stone we spread lime with
it too
spent lime from the beet factory so for
us this was a no-brainer
we probably need a couple more but
this works really well and the nice
thing and what i've looked at doing is
i can take these beaters off and build
windrows also
as a barrier to entry our our feed lot
corresponds with the composting
equipment just perfectly
the only excess piece of equipment i've
had to buy ism is a turner
i mean everything else i can use in the
feedlot the manure spreader this this
has worked out really well for adding my
carbon source to to
my piles um and then you know of course
the the spreader and then trucks and
loaders you know you have those your
you have those already so that that to
me was
was just was awesome when people ask
about you know getting into
into composting if you if you have
cattle already and are feeding or
you know even just a rancher you have
the majority of the equipment already
which is
which is just huge because it's pretty
easy to go and spend a lot of money on
equipment if that's
you know if you're looking to get
started without without that already
this is basically straight manure with
you know we mix
um corn stalks and wheat straw yeah and
this stuff was screened with a quarter
inch screen this is about
oh two two-year-old two-year-old
material so
this would be something i would sell to
a gardener the stuff that i would apply
would have bigger chunks i mean this
stuff
as you can see there's chunks here but
it breaks apart it's it's friable so
um but nothing like it
when i start to turn my product i do
have the end user in mind of what
i i don't want to sell to a local
gardener
or a local landscape or a product that
doesn't look good and so
um i've i've come to the conclusion that
you know that's my machine to make a
good finished product and i also want to
try to screen it if possible so i do
have access to a screener
and that makes a huge difference um and
there's a difference to compost most
people think compost is just
one big thing but you know some of that
finished compost i'll turn
15 times if i have to do it the stuff
that i put on my fields i'll do
a minimum of four normally it ends up
being about six
seven times
it's more of an art than a science is at
the end of the day you have different
conditions it might rain and then you've
got to decide
you know you might have a smell that
doesn't quite smell right i got to go
add some carbon to it so
it does take take some time especially
if you're trying to make that high
quality product
figure out what you're trying to do we
made the mistake of buying one for a
skid steer right away and it was a
complete waste of time it made a good
product
so someone on a small scale i would say
that's a great way to start
we were dealing with my dad's business
in probably three to four thousand tons
a year
and i would say even a loader is too
is too small and it's too slow to to do
a good job
i would recommend right away someone
getting a machine whether it's by
yourself or with a neighbor you know
you're not turning all year so
it's it's probably a machine that that
you can trade with you know
trade time and and labor with but i
would recommend getting a machine now
size wise this is a good way to start
but like i said if if you're wanting to
to be the most efficient a wider machine
would probably
be the best way to go the other mistake
i think a lot of guys starting out
might make is is thinking they can can
get away with just a normal transmission
tractor um you basically have to have a
creeper
an ivt or a hydro to do a good job
because you're
when you're starting off with a big
windrow no matter whether it's this
machine or the other machine i'll show
you you're wanting to go probably less
than half a mile an hour and even slower
because
you're moving a lot of material and once
you start
breaking that material down it does get
easier but you
you'd be riding the clutch a lot on a
tractor so if i were to start and budget
was the biggest thing
a vertica or a horizontal beater manure
spreader
would be able to do would would be able
to do a pretty good job
especially on a small scale because it
starts that process it starts to heat it
up
and then if you have a loader you can
come and turn it later and and you've
got a a decent product especially if
you're just putting on farm ground
i'm never concerned about what other
people think in in
if i was i wouldn't be doing what i'm
doing uh
and i you don't always win
you probably lose more than you win but
i i'm always up for a challenge
and this is probably a real real
challenge
the thing is you've got to be committed
and if you're not committed don't even
start because
it can be trying you know a lot of
people say well compost isn't worth it
or whatever but i
i still think it's got a lot of benefits
you know to composting so
you just don't think that this can have
but this is mother nature
working at its finest